the world's biggest spirits company says
a simple UK supply chain means that
brexit won't have a material impact on
the company Diageo which makes Johnnie
Walker Smirnoff Gordon's and Guinness
said sales and profits were up strongly
during the second half of last year
thanks to growing demand in India and
China we're operating profits jumped by
11 percent and the company is going to
buy back some 660 million pounds worth
of shares and raise the dividend by five
percent I spoke a little earlier to its
chief executive ivan Menezes dr joe as a
company can handle bricks that we can
take it in our stride you will see in
our financial disclosures today we've
said we don't anticipate a material
impact on the company and it's for the
following reasons we make you know Ian
we sell seven bottles of Johnnie Walker
every second around the world but the
product we make has a simple and largely
indigenous supply chain right it's it's
it's Bali peat water women men and time
that makes up expensive scotch whisky
which we then export so our our our
businesses manageable having said all of
that we strongly encourage getting to a
sensible deal quickly we've been for
that for a long time and really would
encourage politicians to to eliminate
the No Deal scenario and get to a
sensible deal
what about Guinness I mean obviously
that crisscross is the Irish border
would you have concerns about a hard
border being imposed we would I mean we
strongly want an open border in Ireland
we have Guinness and Bailey's that
produced north and south and we have
about 13,000 truck crossings a year now
we can handle that however we have a
number of small businesses that work
with us and that could make life
difficult so we really do want to ensure
we keep an open border on the island of
Ireland so what would happen if a hard
border was reimpose what would the
implications be for supplies of Guinness
it would we would it would be a little
more complicated in moving those trucks
back and forth so I mean we can handle
it as a big company
I'd say it's it's more concerning for
small suppliers and the complexity and
costs that that would bring so so we
strongly advocate kind of keeping the
border open but should other scenarios
develop a company like the RG oh we're
fortunate we will be able to handle
those situations without a material
impact on the company now looking at
your results in a bit more detail
they're being concerns about a consumer
slowdown in China from falling profits
warnings from the likes of Apple your
sales in China is strongly ahead yes we
were up 20% in China we have two
businesses there one is the Baiju
Chinese white spirits business raging
Fang which is expensive brands at
consumer price points that business grew
22% and our Scotch whisky business again
the high-end single malts and Johnnie
Walker Blue that too is growing
double-digit so I'm feeling good about
China
we are outperforming the market we're
growing market share the brands are
healthy we've got good teams on the
ground and so we expect to sustain
double-digit growth in China now just
before Christmas you sold 19 of your
less well-known brands is there more
pruning of the portfolio to come I would
say I'm really pleased with the actions
we've taken on the portfolio in the last
few years we exited the wine business
we sold our non-core beer business we
exited hotel business and Scotland and
I'd say the last important piece was
these these value brands in the United
States which we completed a few months
ago just at the end of last calendar you
have completed that transaction we feel
good about this portfolio I mean we're
very disciplined
looking at the portfolio and seeing if
there are opportunities to prune further
I don't anticipate anything major to
happen further I'd say we've done the
the major portfolio management that we
needed to do in the last few years